y la resección transuretral de la
próstata tool por su sigla en inglés es
un procedimiento quirúrgico mediante el
cual se extirpa parte de la glándula
prostática la próstata es una glándula
del tamaño de una nuez en los hombres
que se ubica en la base de la vejiga y
rodea a la uretra lator por lo general
se realiza para tratar una afección
denominada hiperplasia prostática en
esta afección no cancerosa la próstata
se agranda hasta el punto de provocar
dificultad al orinar
también se puede realizar una tool en
pacientes con cáncer de próstata para
liberar la obstrucción de la vejiga
cuando usted llega al hospital para
someterse a la cirugía se le colocará
una vía intravenosa es posible que se le
administren antibióticos para disminuir
la posibilidad de infección una tur que
se puede realizar con anestesia
peridural o general si recibe anestesia
general estará inconsciente y se le
insertará un tubo respiratorio en la
garganta para ayudarlo a respirar
durante la operación si recibe anestesia
peridural permanecerá consciente y
tendrá la parte inferior del cuerpo
anestesiado durante la operación se le
administrará un sedante para ayudarlo a
relajarse una tour sin complicaciones
por lo general tarda alrededor de una
hora
el cirujano introducirá un instrumento
con luz pequeño denominado cistoscopio
por el orificio de la punta del pene
después de instalar solución salina
estéril a través del cis tos copio para
obtener una mejor visibilidad
el cirujano examinará cuidadosamente el
interior de la uretra próstata y vejiga
luego pasar a un receptor escobio que
básicamente consiste en un lazo
conductor pequeño que lleva corriente
eléctrica a través del cis tos copio y
lo usará para cortar las capas del
tejido prostático estos trozos de tejido
se extirpan a través de un puerto de
entrada especial en el sixto copió
cuando se haya extirpado una cantidad
óptima de tejido prostático
el cirujano extraerá el sixto copió y
colocará un catéter en la vejiga para
que siga drenando hasta dos días después
de la cirugía
luego del procedimiento se lo trasladará
al área de recuperación para su
monitoreo y se le administrarán
medicamentos para el dolor si fuera
necesario puede continuar recibiendo
antibióticos a través de la vía
intravenosa y se le puede agregar una
solución salina estéril en el tubo del
catéter para eliminar los coágulos y la
sangre acumulada la mayoría de los
pacientes son dados de alta del hospital
dentro de los dos días de realizado el
procedimiento